[Music]
I'm remiss I must I should have done
this right when you came out but I
didn't congratulations you just got
engaged and I think that's fantastic
[Applause]
what was the experience like of getting
engaged
it's the shocker I was very surprised
we've been together for five years
almost five years and he managed to
surprise me which is wonderful and but
also kind of weird at the same time
because it I went in I blacked out I did
blackout and he came it all happened he
was talking to me and I saw a box and it
just went black so I don't know what
happened the roofied you was I know it
went well because we're planning a
wedding so I know that I must have said
all the right things well when you came
jewelry was he like you said you've been
serious that you black that are you just
got so excited that you kind of yeah it
was just such a surreal moment I mean
that I mean it you know it happens and
you didn't especially when you don't you
don't know that it's gonna happen it
just I don't know it took my breath away
and I was very stunned and shocked and
excited is your family excited are they
gonna as your mom getting into it cuz
moms love to get involved
my mom is now like I told you last time
I was here she got threw up in a yoga
class which was sad I'm sorry I didn't
mentioned that again it was classic
television but now she's like okay
that's it I'm really I'm gonna get into
serious shape for this wedding I'm gonna
look great so she's doing Zumba so I
call her and I said so are you excited
for Zumba tonight it's it's a Latin I
don't know it's nobody is cuz there's a
lot nothing yeah there's like people are
latin-inspired Fitness dance classes but
she goes she goes I'm gonna do it has to
because I don't want to be sore tomorrow
I go but what do you mean half-speed how
do you do a Latin dance it's like if we
kick out this way she's gonna go ya know
so she's doing she's doing Zumba and
she's yeah she's kind of doing it half
my like when you're doing it
is but it's like a sexy kind of dance
because it's like you know kicks and
swirls and spins and you know and men I
wonder how men do it I have not been do
men go to Zumba classes or do they only
go to look at women you know that one in
Maine yes where the prostitute was was
teaching a look that was it so I think
men were going to that one yeah I think
I'm gonna try that zoom yeah of course
there are but it's not forbidden now I
want to try it we have a clip here from
happy endings and congratulations on the
show people really love it you guys are
having trippin success anything we need
to know for this clip
yeah well Dave and I my ex-fiance on the
show are back together and this is us
sort of explaining to the rest of the
gang that we're we're together now let's
take a look well big news out of this
corner these two are going to meet with
a real estate agent and look at
apartments today stop before you start
just stop right in your trap we know
what you're thinking okay
then we're moving too fast but we can't
go backwards we just can't yeah Jane
you're probably like bad idea I'm gonna
do my Kegel exercises and Penny you're
probably like OMG this is so not
amahzing yeah max is all like you guys
are so stupid and so not Ferris and then
Brad he was like oh hell no you two what
is it moving in together
javis turkeys don't even say like that
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that wasn't the right clip for God's
sake and you have a you have a parrot on
the show they do you have a parent and
this parrot is he's racist and
homophobic really the only I love that
idea
he is a parrot that's the way yeah yeah
yeah his only hobby is racism so it's
tough you know to get him interested
another actually when I heard that idea
I thought it's a very funny idea a
racist homophobic Jarrett who
embarrasses everything yeah and we do a
lot of things together too on the show
which is a lot of fun we did like I
brought a picture of us as Thelma and
Louise and we just do a lot of fun we
have that I think you guys messed up his
thumb and Louise on the show that were
parrot